[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're not even gonna have to try this
evening it is Friday night in New York
City man
really
really so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm
Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman it is perhaps the best
day ever man you guys are so [ __ ]
warm and wonderful we're here and one of
the greatest cities in the world this is
a city that inspired me I lived very not
too far away from here over in Jersey
this was the movie that this was the
city that I would look to for
inspiration what not on our way here I
drove past the Angelika Film Center
where I saw slacker that made me want to
be a filmmaker right and but long before
that before I knew I wanted to be a
filmmaker before I saw slacker the thing
that I wanted to do was comedy
specifically very specifically I wanted
to write for SNL yeah and so I went to
school up in the city of The New School
for Social Research Eugene Lange just so
that I could be close to the city even
though like I lived [ __ ] half an hour
away in New Jersey I moved up here just
talking but close to the city so maybe
one day I could write for SNL and I'd
skip classes and I'd go to 30 Rock and I
would sit on the bottom floor man just
waiting for Lorne Michaels to walk by
and be like a fat kid looks funny
maybe the worst idea ever to get a jolly
it was really bad so come in here
tonight and having like a [ __ ] sold
out comedy show on a Friday night you
got it thank you thank you very much now
I think we should have done this a long
time ago I know I don't know why we
waited no that's one reason it's a great
day other reason man don't start don't
[ __ ] start
all I'm saying is if this was the 90s
you know I'd be cast as the penguin man
one of the greatest things ever happened
to me and I didn't see this one [ __ ]
coming a mile away I I do a [ __ ] show
called fat man on Batman in addition to
that I spent 12 years working with the
[ __ ] dude and I could never put two
and two together and see that one
glorious day
Batman would be one of my closest
friends now ordinarily we would put this
story in either the headlines or the
geek news but it is too big to ignore so
we want to start right away by talking
about it for those of you who haven't
heard last night DC Comics and Warner
Brothers announced that they no longer
give a [ __ ] about the character of
Batman big news very big news president
Warner Brothers said and I quote we no
longer give a [ __ ] about that man you're
a raging dick you're like a [ __ ]
supervillain man this is the greatest
thing that ever happened man up dude I
know it's [ __ ] batfleck dude it's
yeah but for a moment if you can take it
[Music]
half-black can you take yourself out of
the equation just for a second oh god no
dude I [ __ ] bought Ben Affleck's
house so that means I own Wayne Manor
now and we all know there's only one
person went to Wayne Manor and kicked
Batman out good day yeah you're bein I'm
[ __ ] bein now man
seriously though yeah that's a Batman
fan is this some cast thing that you you
agree with you said yes you know what I
all the time I was thinking under bite
for Batman you'd run just giant chin is
that what you were thinking what is that
what he's got remember and daredevil was
like radmann just his giant shoe
where's electro boy who you [ __ ] Joan
Rivers man you commenting out of
[ __ ] appearance and she's
saying there's a lot of do to look more
like Batman than this girl [ __ ] he's got
a Batman chin man and he looks exactly
like [ __ ] Bruce Wayne he's got the
[ __ ] of Batman he's down to here I'll
tell you that much
I've seen Batman's dick well that
certainly should be the criteria how
they cast the role
it's down to you and geez jake
gyllenhaal good y'all take your pants
off please we'd like to I have not had
this much [ __ ] fun with Batman since
[Applause]
[Music]
stop it you're encouraging him that's
not what we need tonight the good times
are back man
this is a Batman you could be happy
about and [ __ ] this is good times dude
except for the petition that was
launched today asking Warner Brothers to
change their mind I saw that I saw that
and they have something like 10,000
signatures now yeah well I'm not one of
them all for this idea I think it's
great of all the names that were bandied
about when they started talking about
this casting that was not one I expected
to see well any promising promising
names and then they said his name who
would you rather who would you pick for
best just so many who could be better
Batman than dead Ben Affleck RuPaul
RuPaul RuPaul would be a better Batman
than Ben Affleck look I would pay to see
that version of Batman 2 better Marlee
Matlin would be better as Batman
[Applause]
and you quickly to depend on bu you sir
going to hell number one no I do I pay
double the C [ __ ] bat Marley mate
amazing these are options she can't fire
the grappling gun cuz she's like yeah
yeah Ben Affleck sure is gonna be Batman
yes I blame you why because thank the
credit I think you planted this seed
years ago in that film Jersey girl
amongst the many things I blame Jersey
girl for this is this is one of them
remember that scene where he's driving
his little girl in the in the sweeper
yes we brought could we add that the way
that clip can we should we throw that up
there oh you're right in the Batmobile
aren't you
even his own daughter doesn't want him
to be Batman he's trying to say no
Batmobile that sounds pretty good coming
out of my giant underbite eye I didn't
see coming I had no [ __ ] clue but I'm
happy I think he's I've been on record
many times saying like I think Ben I
thought can be any anything he wants he
can act in anything I think he's an
amazing actor I said he could even play
the shark in a jaws remake so this is
this one I didn't see coming but only
because he seemed beyond this sort of
thing at this point like he did his
superhero movie we need to set a print
of that over 2w be real quickly have you
guys seen daredevil did anybody bother
to screen that for the brass before we
made this decision I know but think
about it man it's practice makes perfect
you got it all out of his system and
[ __ ] so going into his next vigilante
he'll be buddy smooth this dude has
loved Batman going as far back as I can
remember he only did [ __ ] daredevil
because he loved Frank Miller's Dark
Knight Returns he's like they're never
gonna make another Batman says after
Batman had nipples and [ __ ] like that
right so he was like Daredevils cool I
mean Miller wrote him as well so he
liked the character but it was always
rooted in Batman the house his house
that I did wind up buying and [ __ ] when
he when I first got there first saw the
place it was a fourth of July 2001 he
was tore me through the place I come
here come here I gotta show you my
[ __ ] room brings me into the room he
goes look look at this and there's a
side office off his room and there's
this beautiful bookcase and [ __ ] and I
was like that's nice man a lot of books
I'm like he's no no look and he reached
under and he clicked something and all
of a sudden the bookcase one
and [ __ ] literally moved and I was
like no you built a [ __ ] Batcave and
he was like I built a bat cave entrance
that's behind just a giant mirror when
you went in behind the bookcase it was a
panic room it was very small there was a
little TV and a phone and a safe and
[ __ ] and some videogames in case you got
trapped in case somebody came in there's
I'm like that but still it was like he's
always been into the notion he'll he'll
honor the character I honestly think the
dude's great actor in here it makes
absolute sense a lot of people like he's
gonna [ __ ] it up but like Val Kilmer or
Clooney [ __ ] man this dude has been
to the bottom okay he's been a couple
Kevin Smith pictures he knows that's he
knows what it's like to be you know he
got kicked around for a few years people
were like [ __ ] em and [ __ ] then he
crawled clawed his way back to
respectability it should his movie won
Best Picture last year that just this
year so this this is a dude who's been
to the bottom been to the top I know him
I don't think he's looking for a return
to the bottom so I
he's a strategic [ __ ] so I think
for him he's like no this is a smart
move I'm not directing it I'm in it if
you ask me I have well I'd all right I
did speak to him about all the internet
controversy and [ __ ] I talked to him
real quick cuz I was like I'm going
Babylon you want to make a statement and
he did this is the [ __ ] statement
I told them he said he hadn't read the
news I said a lot of people on the
internet are hating on this idea so was
your [ __ ] thoughts on it and this was
his thoughts but all the people hating
it on the movie on the Internet and to
think I asked you to pull yourself out
of the equation for the closest I've
ever come to Batman in my life and [ __ ]
it's kind of amazing but I think he'll
be a great [ __ ] choice there's no way
he drops the ball like here remember in
the last [ __ ] movie where Bane was
like so you come back to die with your
shitty yes and Batman just could have
[ __ ] said anything or could have said
nothing I just rocked him in the [ __ ]
face like [ __ ] you talk I'll [ __ ]
fight but instead What did he say goes
no I come back to stop you one of the
worst lines in cinema history on on
during the error of the batfleck that
will never happen he will always have
something to [ __ ] say in that moment
where you're gonna be like that smooth
that's Affleck
I'm hoping this movie will take place
during the eight years the Batman is
retired just been sitting in an
easy-chair crying cuz he he cries really
good he's a good crier I'll give him
that that's what you want a Batman a guy
who can cry in the drop of a [ __ ] hat
some people are asking dude oh no I tell
you it's gonna be good I promise I
trained this kid I trained I'm like
[ __ ] Liam Neeson man nope put a lot
of people on the internet are gone why
the [ __ ] would he do this he's got like
[ __ ] utter respectability the Argo
Oscar and she could do anything he wants
right why would he do this I think it's
very simple I have not spoken to a bunny
situation he is but I talked about it
last week on Papillon I was like he went
this visit lindsay lohan to Riyadh I'm
like I haven't heard from him in three
years yeah now I hope to get him on
Fatman on Batman at least but uh this
would be my speculation man this is what
I would imagine with you go up to an
eight-year-old kid
mm-hm and you say who's Robert Downey
jr. they go Iron Man you go up to an
eight-year-old kid and say who's Ben
Affleck they look at you blankly or they
say our go [ __ ] yourself you know that's
there's just not the same connection
there man and so if you look at Robert
Downey jr. 'he's berline career over the
last 10 years with all these Marvel
flicks
he went from a dude who has kind of
considered tarnished goods at one point
to a couple films of respectability and
then suddenly you know he was the
linchpin of a new universe of the Marvel
films he became the beacon all that
charm have all the training his entire
life of being Robert Downey jr. being
the charming actor and Jeff boom came to
bear with that [ __ ] character
same things going on with him I would
imagine he looks at it like I could
probably Robert Downey jr. this man I
don't have to [ __ ] direct this I'm
just an actor in this movie it's
Superman and Batman it's not Batman
alone there's gonna be lots of help who
the [ __ ] not gonna see the movie
that's my thought if you're Ben Affleck
you're going okay I got to eat [ __ ] for
what a month on the Internet and take
a month it's so cute
okay movies not coming out until 2015
all right let's make it [ __ ] two
years straight of a mutant [ __ ] no word
at the at the end of the at the end of
the day man everyone in the world is
going to see that movie they're gonna
talk they're talking about calling it a
Superman versus Batman right once that
happens that movie instantly makes two
billion dollars good or [ __ ] bad
it'll make two billion worldwide swear
mark my [ __ ] words 2015 happens
Superman vs Batman makes two billion
easily why wouldn't you want to be
Batman and that somebody's gonna be
Batman why not you and he believes he
could do a good job he's not sitting
there going I can't wait to [ __ ] this up
can you please [ __ ] make the villain
the jail ocher you know
[Applause]
that already happened one night ago
today I'm telling you he will not drop
the [ __ ] ball like the dude is at
this point in his career struggling to
get back to where he is and [ __ ] he's
at the top of the mountain in a world
were [ __ ] everybody when agro 1 there
wasn't anybody sitting there going go
[ __ ] yourself people were totally back
on his side man it was weird to watch
like in one full swoop were there like a
Ben Affleck's Batman everyone's like
[ __ ] man they ass he's got a girl
what is Matt Damon robbing and [ __ ]
so right away of course he's he's like
goes from where the place where
everyone's like utter respectability
just like boom he could take it this is
a dude who took being kicked in the
teeth for a long time I doubt he's even
paying attention to the stuff on the
internet
I think he's got well then we need to be
louder than we really knew honestly feel
like it's not it's a bad bad choice
really man bad casting decision yeah
what about a bug I think I think he's an
OK actor I think he does serviceable
work in the right projects [ __ ] get
you on my movie posters dude serviceable
work in the right project Ralph Garman
but I think he's like [ __ ] this is a
movie kinda Ralph Garman I just think he
lacks the gravity I think he lacks the
intensity you should go look at dog man
some really [ __ ] intense he's a dog
but I won't even point I mean to us mean
to us he's so mean oh you're thinking of
Matt Damon bad Ben was a lot more
serious no you don't even have to look
at my work just look at some look at
there's a awesome performance he gave in
changing lanes very dark very [ __ ]
like combative self combative here's a
woof this fantastic monologue that he
does at the end of the movie with his
wife watch that flick why watch I mean
you can look at his own movies he's
pretty damn good in his flicks but a lot
of people on the net or like let him
direct don't let him be Batman to be
honest I uh I between that character and
a plethora of other characters I always
saw more of a Superman myself I think he
has the classic looks of a Superman that
parts taken they're offering him Batman
he'd be stupid not to do it dude like I
said they could put me in the [ __ ]
suit and make two billion dollars man
they might make three cuz people like I
gotta [ __ ] see this I've never seen
that much latex before you guys are off
by a letter in that title
I like the idea you had from before when
you made that comic book after after
Mallrats
remember though the comic book cover you
made featuring I called this back in 95
I predicted Ben Affleck as [ __ ] can
we throw out the cover of the comic book
that Kevin created for him that's it's
the but the but man adventures from the
opening credits of all rights even back
then I was like this guy is a Bruce
Wayne he's a total Bruce Wayne man and
Batman and come on what's with all due
respect to everyone who's ever worn the
cow you know you put on the mask and you
pick a voice and [ __ ] the mask does
most of the work for you man you see
it's that kind of thinking that got us
where we are today you just gotta be
able to kind of brood and stuff you know
not every Batman is brooding
hello good people of Gotham waited my
whole life to say that in the real
Gotham and here we are
see Adam West sent out a tweet to Ben
today did you see that no what did he
say he said along with the role comes a
lot of heat and perspiration buy
deodorant he said it's cuz he's gonna
stink that's why oh he's gonna rock he's
gonna [ __ ] Affleck tit dude did you
see the Richard Dreyfuss tweet I thought
that was adorable no Richard Dreyfuss
Dreyfuss put it between he goes you work
real hard on an audition you try your
hardest then they cast the young guy see
what do you think the voice is gonna
sound like here's my this would be my no
stupid crime
dude it's not [ __ ] Taylor Lautner
it's like stupid cry my parents all got
murdered and junk
to say is a little light little light
for my taste
Lizzy yeah I don't for me I'm fully
committed the voice is the thing I want
to ask you about though the voice here
would be my vote for the boys there's a
lot of people even as much as they love
Bale and Nolan's Batman everyone picked
universally on the boys are deaf I got
my truck so what oh no no no [ __ ]
nobody's going that if now but every
actor does the voice differently like
when they're Bruce Wayne they speak in
their normal voice as Batman they drop
it a few actives octaves or try
something else
I would suggest they go for something
this time where they give him a [ __ ]
like he says I've built in a voice a
little modulator lays against his throat
extent make it [ __ ] around with his
voice and post and make it creepy and
[ __ ] like that nobody's done that yeah
but I think I know what the [ __ ] been
bat voice is gonna sound like man I got
it right here but a flight was the bomb
and phantoms
could you imagine man he's [ __ ] got
you you [ __ ] mug somebody grabs you
hold you over a [ __ ] roof edge of a
roof of building and [ __ ] and then all
of a sudden he [ __ ] says but Affleck
was the bomb and phantoms what you don't
want to see that Batman I didn't know
how you'd take it - I remember like when
I you didn't everyone else in this room
knew how I was gonna take it I didn't I
thought it could go either way I thought
you might be like wait on good choice I
didn't know that you would be so against
how little you know me after three years
by the laces our three year anniversary
of doing it happy Anniversary sweetheart
happy Anniversary reducer give that
penis a sandwich yeah all right
let's get on with the [ __ ] show man
that's enough about Ben well we can all
tell already from the opening of the
show how high you must be the only thing
we don't know is what you're smoking
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are you smoking tonight keV
I don't know that explains so much
epaulettes dick what are you smoking
tonight
dude forgive me for doing a little dick
sucking man I'm trying to get [ __ ]
Jason Mewes hired as the Riddler as most
travelers of the green know when you're
out of town man you're at the mercy of
what comes your way and so whatever
comes my way I'm lugs are poison in it
though like no Mike all right but it's
very lovey-dovey it makes me very
friendly yeah all right now each and
every week we also like to give some
shout outs the people who become
particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions it's a
segment we call the shout outs
[Music]
[Applause]
we're in New York come on class it up a
little bit my bad
by the way a record number of shoutouts
were sent to us for this show tonight
and most of you can be horribly
disappointed so just keep that in mind
Michelle you cruel rakuyo hi Michelle I
want to give a shell a shout-out cuz
she's here by herself tonight she had to
[ __ ] up really are you alone yeah she
said someone late man are you kidding me
this is the day that Ben Affleck became
Batman anything's possible man we all
have fallen it's not be easy it's a geek
holiday have you ever wanted to have sex
with a quasi celebrity I could hook it
up
Michelle writes I would have brought
along my best friend Virginia and her
husband Jake but they're unavailable due
to Virginia's vagina being a ticking
time bomb that sounds horrible
we should call Homeland Security she is
due any moment to give birth to their
first child Beatrix as the fathers of
daughters yourselves could you give them
some advice on keeping their little
Beatrix from turning into a Kim
Kardashian or a Lindsay Lohan no
impressions need it since my favorite
celebrities are you guys we could
totally hook up that sex thing man
she doesn't even want impression I know
totally wobbly h-her the real route no
no I'll just watch from under a glass
table and masturbate while I'm doing it
dude I'm gonna be playing this [ __ ]
song stop it
[Applause]
well Kevin said that the father of a
teenager there's the difficult years my
daughter's still a toddler that's easy I
just have to distract her with sugar and
and Hello Kitty things but I am trying
to steer her towards lesbianism I've
decided to make a concerted effort
trying to make her lesbian because I
just can't picture any man ever touching
her you know it's funny being a man once
you have a daughter changes your
perspective on everything not at all for
you were a good man it doesn't change a
[ __ ] thing oh well it does for me
[Applause]
anyway I just keep telling I just keep
pointing to my penis saying bad bad bad
so when she's in court one day and
they're pointing to the Ralph's doll
she's like used to point here and say
bad yeah and sadly my wife does the same
thing about my penis she gets cornea
anything bad bad so that's my advice
just steer her towards lesbianism I'm
gonna counter that because I tried to
steer my daughter towards lesbianism at
14 she's interested in nothing but boys
even now I'll sit around the dinner
table and be like I love [ __ ] yeah it
didn't work man so you know what just be
the person I mean this doesn't go for
women women know exactly how to raise a
[ __ ] another woman so you need no
advice there but for the man in the
relationship man you just want to be the
person that eventually your daughter
winds up falling in love with or at
least interested or something like that
you can't fault yourself if she brings
home an ass all that men that she
watched you be an [ __ ] to her mom
somewhere along line so just treat her
mother like [ __ ] gold everything else
will follow even if her mother's an
overbearing [ __ ] just treat her like
treat illegal never tell the kid that
part just keep it inside all right
angina and [ __ ] like that but in front
of the kid it's nothing but love and
flowers and [ __ ] like and then she'll
always pick the right guy
good advice thank you all right
John and JC from Brooklyn you guys are
in charge holy [ __ ] oh that was close
sup boys get out anyway three years no
it's good [ __ ] yourself
dude be happy you know what usually
follows I waited three years of this of
God I'm your biggest fan
welcome man I waited three years for
this as well JC and China from Brooklyn
representing this is rare we got this
last week we rarely get a chance to
actually [ __ ] be so close to the
people that wrote - yeah they are I'm
just gonna stare creepily which one he
wrote it John you're the writer
yeah read his letter all right my
girlfriend of two and a half years
hasn't listened to a full episode of
Babylon yet hold the thought which one's
the girlfriend JC you know jazzy is it
Jay
Jesse Jesse your name's Jesse and you've
never listened to an episode of the show
only a little bit cuz you're like
there's never enough talk about Ben
Affleck yeah go back to readin go back
to reading I think it's due to the fact
that I bug her writes John all the time
imitating your John Travolta impression
first of all leave it to the [ __ ]
professionals job you'll be hearing from
my lawyer he's doing it he's doing it I
hear him it's like it's happening in the
wild it's awesome do it again do it
again
I don't know why but he's singing grease
it would be an honor if the infamous
geckos could tell Jessie what an episode
full of Babylon is like your biggest fan
John garmi Brooklyn division what why
we're so weird
but wait first then your kill when you
die and then your spirit Rises boo there
we go it's so refreshing when [ __ ] a
boyfriend writes in he's now like can
you convince my girl to give me a needle
yeah
we're light on the anal tonight good
yeah other than Ben Affleck taking you
in the hind er it's the only
representation of you one of us is
visiting the Batcave and they gonna be
mr. sourpuss
Anthony Pete Rachel and Anthony you guys
here you don't [ __ ] care at all about
this show do it everyone else has been
very exciting you're like yeah we're
here like too much a flag
Anthony writes here with my friends Pete
Rachel and Anthony although he shares
the same name with me he is
significantly lamer you'll be able to
tell us apart because the lame anthony
is not the one is the one not drinking
because he doesn't drink at all I'm with
you
why why is that bad get the [ __ ] out of
this nightclub I'm with you his first
beer my work here is done the [ __ ]
dude looks like a deer in headlights
he's like why am I being forced to drink
awesome that's why we looked like it was
high school all over again man
don't worry you don't have to drink if
you don't want to and no no no but if
you want to focus my weed could could
the Germans please tell him to stop
being such a [ __ ] and have a beer with
his friends tonight
okay yeah it's a problem to be drinking
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah beer is very
important in that you know social
history and all these things have an
entire holiday if it wasn't for beer
ugly people would never have sex it's
very important and people would make
wise decisions always yeah yeah and
nobody would be texting the exes in the
middle of the night yeah it's important
why are you so unhappy Anthony more
beers for Anthony I think I can keep the
peel he looks like the Fuhrer in the
bunker just before the end
get my German Shepherd out of here we
saw how about the Travis and Melissa and
TJ are you guys here that's what I'm
talking about
holy [ __ ] I felt like Ted Nugent for a
minute man that was a way worthier woe
than I deserve thank you TJ from Oakdale
Long Island with his friends Travis and
Melissa I just turned 25 I'm here with
my two best friends Travis and Melissa
who just got married in May gratulations
and they said it wouldn't last
and yet here they are sometimes I feel
like I spend more time crashing on their
floor than I do in my own home well that
must make them very happy as newlyweds
TJ really is DJ on the floor again I
think he's masturbating I'm incredibly
lucky to have them on my life they
aren't very familiar with the show but
they're huge Batman fans so if Bane
could please let them know how much I
love them and how much I appreciate
everything they do for me
TJ writes to Travis and Melissa so what
this is Travis oh here we go again I got
to get out of pie chard and to be a
diagram and it's from TJ yes to Travis
and Melissa so only three people
involved in the [ __ ] email
one of them wrote it that takes one out
of the equation
talk to the other too [ __ ] hard on me
man
I didn't know I'd be doing math tonight
let me get in character man lying face
table saw it seems that TJ is always
over a chop all
I smell a three-way sub does pictures
that'd be painful a three-way like that
for the mr. bean why oh wow Garber would
it be painful I'm just saying go 3-1 yes
would be very painful for you oh it
would be bad balls oh you know thank you
[Applause]
how about Pat and Steph you guys here
tonight my name is Pat my wife is Steph
we moved to New York about a year ago a
year and a half ago but we're both
native philadelphians and we miss our
hometown a lot
[Applause]
I got a worse reaction than Ben Affleck
is Batman they right could Rocky Balboa
please tell us what Philadelphia how
Philadelphia is such a great city
Babylon patents death it almost down you
will fulfill adelphia you living there
was like a good city hall and then you
moved to New York it's like you know
Philadelphia been good to you as a home
and all like with people that would
probably love you and then you leave
yeah you leave to go another city but
you like my home but my home sticks
you're like my home you're greedy lazy
that's right
do you believe Ben Affleck is Batman
it's like mentally regular you shut your
mouth
and lastly Debra writes in she's here
with her boyfriend Frank you guys here
right up front that's very uncomfortable
for us
she looks mortified yeah wait
he made you write this letter you're
like I love it in the water in Jaws you
like he made me do it this is gonna be
bad I'm gonna look right at you while it
happens and don't ask me where my other
hand is it's right here
they've been together for a year she
writes a year ago I went to a doctor who
premier held in the city here I met a
lot of people that day one of whom
showed up and a doctor whose shirt and
some sexy Dalek socks who which one
I bet you didn't know when you were
dressing that day we're gonna get [ __ ]
for it because no one wearing a doctor
who shirt and Alex ox has ever been laid
ever in the history of mankind it's like
hitting the [ __ ] Powerball lottery of
sex
it was geeky love at first sight right -
Debra a year later and he still hasn't
had it had any lucky getting his sonic
screwdriver up my chocolate TARDIS she
sold you out [ __ ] she's pointing going
he wrote this because it is definitely
not bigger on the inside she writes
about her yeah it's pretty strong we're
celebrating our one-year anniversary be
awesome if David Bowie could wish us a
happy anniversary
sure why not why not happy anniversary
you geeks happy anniversary who viens
it's so nice when geeks get to have sex
happy Anniversary to you too Debra and
to Frank
[Music]
[Applause]
happy anniversary Declan over Surrey -
you two cakes you found each other at a
Doctor Who premiere happy anniversary
Debra happy Anniversary - Frank
all right that's enough
even though we've never done a show here
I wish I could say I've never done that
in New York before but yeah well we are
in Chelsea we also get emails from all
around the world featuring Kevin's
reactions first email is from listener
John he said with Sylvester Stallone
firing Bruce Willis from Expendables 3
we should have seen this coming
apparently Willis feels bad about things
and is trying to make amends okay
have you seen this photograph on the
internet no maybe the picture of Bruce
Willis trying to make things right he's
he's coming clean
let's throw up that shot of Bruce Willis
there we go trying to make amends the
greedy lazy that's right put the sign on
those right you had me dude for a second
I was just like that'd be so awesome
yeah like Bruce Willis ever feels bad
about anything he ever does ever true
last week we showed a video these oh my
god why did I never think of that before
who said it you throw it out there loud
what was it
douche Willis last week we showed that
video there's two little girls trying to
audition for Britain's Got Talent and
the mother barge into the room and say
which one of you took a [ __ ] and then
you flush
apparently it's become quite the
internet phenomenon Mike in Liverpool
England writes heard you guys talking
about that video last week I was
laughing hysterically had a search for
at YouTube and myself and I came across
this version which I think you'll like
seeing the Breaking Bad is now in its
final season the toilet flush mom showed
up when Hank learned the truth on
Breaking Bad check it out for yourselves
here's the video wash the toilet after
that have a shaped well was [ __ ] one a
yes the starts time yeah it's worse than
the real thing
and after listening to last week's
awesomeness of Harrison Ford singing
Mahna Mahna
writes JT man a hoist city Pennsylvania
we did it thing we someone wrote and
said I love the song phenomena from the
Muppets but I keep hearing Harrison Ford
singin and we did that last week
JT writes for the love of all things
holy could please hear Al Pacino do the
Mahna Mahna song
your wish is our command here we go
Oh Menominee Mahna Mahna Mahna Mahna
Mahna Wow there we go
Pacino would have been a better Batman
I'd like to see but you know I just I
love you along those lines this email
kicks us off for babbles storytime your
favorite children books read in the
voices of your favorite celebrities
listen up you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's babbles
storytime gather round kitties drew
Helmick writes it would be funny as hell
to hear Charlton Heston reading the
children's classic everyone poops fair
enough an elephant makes a big poop
[Laughter]
a mouse makes a tiny food a one hump
camel makes a one a two hump camel makes
a to hump poop only kidding ah there you
go
each and every week we're saying about
some people in show business who had
careers and left us too soon in this
particular case is our weekly edition of
the tinsel town stiffs
[Music]
this was sad news this week Lee Thomas
young and if you're familiar with him or
not he was on NASA nosey although I'm
sorry Lee Thompson young my bet he was
on Rizzoli and Isles that's the
currently the show he's currently
Wignall but everyone remembers him as
the famous Jett Jackson if you watch
that show in the Disney Disney Channel
for many years he was also in the movie
version of Friday Night Lights really
talented actor a lot of charisma he was
the black kid what we gone it's been a
long time since I've seen that movie
yeah Lee Thompson young was found at the
age of 29 years old after taking his own
life in his home self-inflicted
inflicted gunshot wound I know he was
always working a super-talented Kris met
a kid everyone said that worked for them
said he was just a sweet guy and no one
really knows what the reasoning was it
but he was found in his home and he
didn't show up for work they checked out
his house the police did and they found
them there as a tribute I just want to
bring a little taste of the opening of
the famous Jett Jackson the show I
enjoyed the hell out of his little video
featuring Lee Thompson young
[Applause]
one mission at a time please that's what
play on TV
I remember just as a kid watching him
saying what this guy charisma he just
came out through the screen he was
always really watchable yeah I always
had a great quality he will be missed
but gonna win one of the great directors
yeah absolutely give it up one of the
great movie and TV directors ted post
passed away this week at the age of 95
he was one of those directors like an
old school director who directed
everything he did like 60 episodes of
Gunsmoke on television he did everything
in the 60s he worked on a Western called
rawhide it was on that show that he met
a young man named Clint Eastwood and
Clint Eastwood asked him after he came
back from Italy and he'd done those
spaghetti westerns to direct him in hang
them high remember that movie hang em
high the later went on to direct the
second Dirty Harry movie Magnum force is
also oh he dropped the first time that
he says that's not when he says go ahead
make my day that's way let's way later
yeah he also dresses the one his magnum
force where he explains like this is the
math of Magnum 40 Bob oh no I think
that's Dirty Harry I think that's the
first that's the first yeah I don't know
what happened in there oh my god sorry
I'm sorry I don't know who lead Thompson
young played in Friday Night Lights and
I don't know the lines of Magnum force
I'll go I'll go to Wikipedia after this
all right yeah directed beneath the
Planet of the Apes also what ah he did
the knee good guys wear black with Chuck
Norris that welcome back to beneath so
that's the moment the missile underneath
that's the one with the radio I told
myself to my bomb and [ __ ] like that was
a creepy movie rich man poor man the
miniseries dreg I worked all the time
but hang them high is one my favorite
Western so is a tribute to him I brought
in one of my favorite scenes with Clint
Eastwood from hang them high let's take
a look
you'll remember me no you hang a man you
better look at him
[Music]
don't go for that gun right now I need
you alive and that guy's defense he only
had one eye you know you can't expect it
out of the one eye to remember what you
looked like because he's always seen
half of you or something right is that
how that works are we still talking
about the director no we're talking
about the guy in the scenes you don't
see enough patches anymore people need
to wear more eye patches yeah cuz that's
not intimidating it's a good look
and lastly Elmore Leonard passed away
this was a bummer
great great author passed away at 87
years old wrote forty five novels over
forty five novels many of them were
adapted for film and television
justified the series right now it's in
the elephant that's one of his movies
hombre 52 pickup out of sight get shorty
Jackie Brown 3:10 to humi twice be cool
kill shot freaky deaky all those made
into films Quentin Tarantino was a huge
fan of his websites him as the
inspiration for his dialogue writing as
well get shorty I think may have been
one of my favorite adaptations of his
though for a feature film here's a
little scene from that film do mom look
at me I am looking at you now look at me
the way I'm looking at you
put it in your eyes you're mine [ __ ]
without saying it okay how about this
what are you telling me that a sleepy
it's so weird you sleepy
boo huge bucket a win for Elmore Leonard
yeah what a life what a career each and
every week we also take a look at TV and
film any project hundreds of pairs of
eyes take a look at it before it reaches
you the audience however [ __ ] still
slips through the cracks and sometimes
we catch it and when we catch the [ __ ]
it's called [ __ ] that should not be this
week's kind of is kind of a cheat
because the movie in question is called
kindergarten ninja so what do we show in
the whole movie pretty much it's Aaron
here by the way Aaron yeah Aaron was the
one who sent this in thanks Aaron for
giving me the heads up for kindergarten
ninja it is a kids movie it's basically
for children it was made in the 80s
early 80s stars NFL player Dwight Clark
probably most famous Ford the catch in
the NFC playoffs and when he played for
San Francisco in the back of the endzone
and they remember him yeah it was 80s
let it go
he plays blade steel in this film a
womanizing Boozer who hates children and
yet is somehow still the protagonist in
this children's film called kindergarten
ninja Dwight Clark by the way would be a
better choice for Batman than Ben
Affleck
now the reason I showed that it's a
low-budget film it really shouldn't be
taking shots at it because it's it's you
know they didn't have much to work with
however they did something just
unforgivable in this film they
apparently didn't have the the time or
the concern or the motivation or the
budget for a slow motion moment during
one of the fight sequences and so rather
than slow down the footage they had the
actors acted out in slow motion eyes
excellent balls see if you fall in love
like I did with kindergarten ninja
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah I don't care how low your
budget is just [ __ ] don't do that
just don't do that it's a choice man you
know it's not a choice you're not
fooling anybody that was the one
director in the history of movies who
were like what if we didn't slo-mo us
what if we slow mode old-school
[Music]
also every week we take a look at some a
list actors who at some point in their
career have turned into less than a list
performance it is exquisite acting any
actor now how good they are as capable
of giving a bad performance and
sometimes the performances are so bad
they come all the way around and become
exquisite that is the case this week
with a film from Michael Mann a cult
classic from 1983 called the keep as
anyone ever seemed to keep its I still
don't know what the [ __ ] it's about
quite frankly I've seen this movie it's
about they find the Germans find this
thing it's like during World War two and
they find this thing and there's like a
creature inside of it and they they get
ian mckellen legendary actor Ian
McKellen - he's Jewish historian and
they take him out of a concentration
camp so they help them figure out how to
harness this creature this power inside
the key and he falls under its spell and
he thinks it's one thing it turns out
that it's evil and in a very classic
moment in the film he realizes that he
has been working for this creature that
is inherently evil and he has the Silver
Cross that apparently has some power
over this creature and he says if you're
if you're really who you say you are
then you simply can take this cross away
from me but Ian McKellen does it in a
style that makes it truly exquisite
here's that scene a keep is a prison to
contain you and you have lied exploited
deceived and you are the same evil as
outside this place so you prove yourself
to me
you take it out of here know yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and to that that it looks like magneto
the disco years yeah he's got max Rex
hair from yes Batman Returns you
talented Hollywood babble-on listeners
each and every week you send in your
Photoshop photographs of Kevin in places
he simply does not belong it's my
favorite game it's called keV in
[Music]
[Music]
what's keV in this week you can go to
the Kevin game tumblr.com if you want to
check out some of these suggestions
yourself this first one comes from Mark
Dominguez from San Diego he says an
honor of Sunday's season finale of True
Blood maybe you saw Kevin's appearance
in the finale if you didn't we have the
photo of him and his man crush Alexander
Skarsgard can we throw that picture up
there we go
drew Boehner Eric
tears Kevin some new holes it says there
on the bottom
did you see do you watch True Blood I I
do I did not see the finale for no
explicable reason well he spoilers if
you haven't seen it you see his dick you
must have been so pleased holy [ __ ] I
was like stake me [ __ ]
it is he you know it's well hidden he's
sitting in a chair so you think like
they're not gonna show it he's very
often in that show kind of completely
naked but they don't show the best
partnership and I'm really looking you
know in this scene he's sitting in this
[ __ ] chair you don't think you think
once again you're not gonna see it but
he's forced to [ __ ] get up and when
he gets up man he's got a [ __ ] smoky
killer right down here man long as [ __ ]
just [ __ ] luscious Ralph alright
alright holy [ __ ] it's a good-looking
man okay alright how good thing for you
to say to me on our third anniversary by
the way are you kidding me if I brought
back [ __ ] him to bed with us you
wouldn't be like alright yeah he's right
kevin and i as i mentioned we do in this
show for three years although many of
you may remember us from our film work
in the 70s of course we were starring
alongside of Burt Reynolds in Smokey and
the Bandit if you saw that film as big
eNOS and little eNOS do you remember
those characters it's good times with
Burt good times please wear your hair
like that for the next year well I'm
growing the mullet that's next and
Kevin's career has been up and down of
course as we know and I'm just saying we
all have we all have moments of raging
success and sometimes less your success
but Kevin's a smart man sometimes eeeh
he is divested his money you may
remember his short-lived short-lived
restaurant chain Kev's big boy do you
remember kids big boy
we throw that up there there we go I
always enjoyed their food I always
thought it was I always enjoyed your
food
thank you we make a hell of a burger
this you do every week of course that's
the reason we're here we take a look at
all of the entertainment news headlines
with the HBO headlines
[Music]
the lion in the news this week
[Applause]
[Music]
now I know why Lindsey has not come to
her senses before now turns out no one
gives a [ __ ] about a sober Lindsey Lohan
why she was on Oprah Winfrey this past
weekend okay
an exclusive post-rehab interview and
everyone said Oprah was lucky to get it
it was it was a big get well no one
tuned in to watch no really less than a
million viewers tuned in on Sunday night
to watch the lindsay interview as
opposed to her interview with Lance
Armstrong worth 3.2 million people tuned
in for that one and much less than her
interview with Whitney Houston's
daughter Bobbi Kristina three point five
million viewers tuned in to watch the
daughter of somebody whose famous name
is Lea Lohan less than a million no one
wanted to hear from do you think it's
because like in the case of Lance
Armstrong he had nobody knew the details
in the case of Bobbi Kristina she was
able to give them information we didn't
all know but her Lindsay Lohan's life
has been so [ __ ] open book like what
could you really sit down an interviewer
about that he wouldn't sit like I'd be
afraid if I was the other person I'd be
like oh yeah I read that everything she
said I feel like I read that I saw that
on TV i watch the video like it's just
it's all out there on the record I think
she's just not as interesting when she's
not loaded and airtight that's what it
is oh we like her as a train wreck we
like her as a train wreck she's not that
interesting just as a person over
familiarity in the case of Lindsay lamb
we know way too much about already and I
guess a lot of people were just like why
am I gonna want it all so a lot of
people knew that she got paid right yeah
there was a big paycheck attached maybe
some people stayed awake so like Fargo I
want to change the system it won't
change but at least maybe they made some
sort of statement or maybe nobody like
me can find [ __ ] own on their channel
yeah because I want to watch a few Tyler
Perry shows they've teamed up for some
[ __ ] man I like Tyler Perry you're
seeking Tyler Perry out yes I respect
his model of work he's like an indie
filmmaker man who took it to you guys
that's Spike Lee in the back bitter in
any of them
MTV Teen Mom Farrah Abraham in the news
again this week
she of course did that movie backdoor
Teen Mom for vividly
hoo-yeah anal sex house a quick
turnaround man did about this be very
glad that Farrah Abraham has not been
cast as Batman there you go yeah she did
an interview this week saying that
rumors about her being an escort are
untrue she will not have sex for money
except for that time when she had sex
for money
she also tweeted a long list of
expensive items that she'd like from
amazon.com that she would like her fans
to buy for her isn't that code online
for like Lindsay Lohan in the back of
the audience tonight I know this is
something that a lot of these women do
especially porn stars they will just
release a list of things they would like
as gifts and their fans will buy them
for them with just for the hell of it
just for them just to say that I bought
this girl this thing and she thanked me
for it
I tell desperate and lonely some people
are here's the list a $900 evening gown
$1,400 bookcase
she doesn't [ __ ] read she needs
something to hold on to while she's
getting nailed from behind make it
sturdy what are these they're books oh
$700 cocktail dress a 650 $750 pink
crystal chandelier Wow you know those
are essentials yeah
and an industrial drum of anal ease
lubricant that's what I got her
Justin [ __ ] Bieber
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right I caught a lot of [ __ ] this
week it wasn't my fault but apparently
we did a story last week we put Justin
Bieber in the Hollywood helpers yes
because his public relations team went
into overdrive last week announcing that
his 200th Make A Wish Foundation meet up
with some kid was record breaking that
he had given more kids their wishes than
anybody else had and his public
relations team was very proactive with
that and put it all over the newspapers
it was a big story turns out that John
Cena the wrestler John Cena has almost
400 make a wish fulfilled fulfillment
that he has done over his career
dwarfing Justin Bieber's achievement so
Bieber was even lying about the good
things that he does I mean that's like
over a year's worth of make a wish
because they don't like like he got five
today you know now it's one at a time at
a time that's that's like over a year of
his life has been dedicated to at some
point of the day sitting down with some
kid who may not make it man hats off to
[ __ ] say you know who knew that so I
wanted to give him a shout-out yeah set
the record straight lot of celebrities
in cars this week Dick Van Dyke had to
be rescued from a burning car this yes
no yes really why would I lie that was
like the opening of the show his car hit
an ottoman
and burst into flames a lady goes rocked
man he was on the 101 freeway in
California on the side of the road and
his car had burst into flames and was
filled with smoke oh [ __ ] and a driver
saw it came by and so on and they say
here an elderly man slumped over the
wheel of his Jaguar and went in open the
door and dragged Dick Van Dyke out -
which I'm thinking Dick Van Dyke get out
of the [ __ ] car your cars on fire why
did someone have to drag him out he was
fine though he's okay and the Highway
Patrol showed up and they put the car
out and all is well but we almost lost
dick he was he was also D and [ __ ] and
then they knew he was better when he was
like Jim Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy the
Jaguar is a British car I was thinking
was trying to murder him for the
accident that he didn't mary poppins
maybe that's why they still hold a
grudge
the former Partridge Family star David
Cassidy got pulled over for drunk
driving this week how old is he 63 years
old dubbed in an Asian film or something
watch it again do it again
yeah oldest he's 63 years old Kevin
[Applause]
come on get ancient we had to Dave's
mugshot I think the throw up there he's
looking good these days yeah 63 man he's
not supposed to look like David
Partridge anymore Keith Partridge hello
Oh Keith Partridge my bad you're right
he was pulled over this is actually a
pretty great story he was pulled over in
Albany cops noticed that he was driving
with his high beams on his nipples were
very hard they pulled him over they gave
him a sobriety test which he failed then
they had him blow the breathalyzer it
was a point 1 0.08 is the legal limit so
he's well over but here's the best part
of the story
the arresting officer introduced himself
the officer's name was Tom Jones
according to the district attorney when
Jones introduced himself David Cassidy
responded with what's new pussycat
[Applause]
case dismissed you may go mr. Cassidy if
I was the judge I would just if you're
that quick you can't be that that's
right it's better than I could come up
with a lot of people want a cardboard
sign of David Hasselhoff you hurt me he
is selling nice coffee now have you seen
these commercials with David House F
there's big cardboard signs of him
outside the convenience stores he's
selling this brand of iced coffee and
they have become a very hot item so much
so that over the last few months
according to officials more than 500
have been stolen from stores along the
east coast college kids or big Baywatch
fans I'm guessing yes we got the sign I
think here's what is what the sign looks
like well look at that how could you
resist I want to steal one right now
okay I guess you could take that home
put a giant [ __ ]
hands and [ __ ] there was a 36 year old
clerk at a Cumberland Farms store who
saw a man and a woman stealing two of
these outside of his store one am
putting them in his SUV the worker ran
out of the store and jumped on the SUV
to stop him oh my god it's like an
episode of Baywatch was dragged for
several miles and then fell and hit his
head let it go buddy
he's currently hospitalized in critical
condition for trying to save a cardboard
David Hasselhoff dude you work in a
[ __ ] convenience store how what
you're not getting paid enough to stop
crime you should have been fined again
spending all of his time making movies
and that's right he wasn't supposed to
be here today that was cute don't you
think next week's Hollywood helper
should be a story about how to visit
that cat yeah wouldn't that be nice I
think he tweeted something at him yeah
but it could not be understood because
he was way drunk when he did I don't
think it's a big deal anymore when a
celebrity comes out and says I'm gay but
I thought this was pretty cool this week
Wentworth Miller star of Prison Break
before with him if they'd have been
rumored for some time that he was gay
but he publicly admitted it this week
but for a very good reason he was
invited to the st. Petersburg
International Film Festival in Russia I
know have you been following what's
going on in Russia they just passed the
law saying that at no time can there be
any public discussion of gay rights or
gay relationships anywhere where
children might hear it which is just
prehistoric he was invited to the film
festival and he wrote the following
letter thank you for your kind
invitation as someone who has enjoyed
visiting Russia in the past who can also
claim a degree of Russian ancestry it
would make me happy to say yes however
as a gay man I must decline and he sent
a message which I think is cool
another star came out this week Lucas
Cruikshank you know Fred the Fred videos
on YouTube you ever seen Fred Fred is a
phenomenon started off as a YouTube
thing and now he's got his own show on
Nickelodeon it's like this monster thing
you guys know Fred it's it's it's
unbearable it's really so annoying but
fred has come out as being gay and if we
were all not shocked at all here's
here's Fred for those of you have never
seen Fred here's a little Fred video we
were all shocked it was like finding out
that the Affleck was gonna be Batman it
was that kind of shock and then he got a
shout out from share by the way when he
broke the news really which is like a
Catholic getting blessed by the Pope
pretty much
the cameraman who got assaulted by Kanye
West is suing there's a surprise I hope
you guys remember the video but this is
after he said don't talk don't talk to
anyone who ever talked to anyone else
and don't talk to anyone who knows
anyone and don't talk to you know that
guy after he said that there was a
paparazzo but I'm not a big fan of the
paparazzo I think they can be invasive
and and and at best a rude and
inconsiderate and sometimes dangerous
but this guy was pretty [ __ ] funny
because after Kanye West had never
talked to me he was like why can't I
talk to you why can't I be was like Miss
poking them a little bit so much so the
con us o kicked his ass here's the video
why can't we talk to you I mean why I
mean no no come on Kanye I don't want to
fight with you dude seriously I don't
want to fight without disaster
are you Tom would you try to kill me
yeah this guy said he needed to walk
with crutches for two weeks after the
attack what did he do on them did he say
hurt his feelings walk on crutches
have you seen Mel Gibson recently no 57
year old Mel Gibson talking to pop-up
paparazzo someone caught him coming out
of the gym this week you gotta see this
picture of Mel Gibson looking back oh
I've never seen him look so jacked he's
huge
[Applause]
57 years old they say he's getting ready
for Expendables 3 he's been cast in
Expendables 3 he's got some [ __ ]
sugar tits don't make me look at those
look at those guns how huge his arms are
they say he's been list lifting
incredibly heavy things he's been doing
curls with his anti-semitism which is
enormous by the way very large Sylvester
Stallone was like in this movie you
might have to do some judo he's like no
now I went to that greedy loser
another day another a nude photo scandal
in Hollywood Phu Demi Lovato's Willy
with Demi Lovato what are you good then
making that face one day I want to be
somebody I know here's a picture of Demi
Lovato here's a look how hot she is
she's adorable that was the little girl
from what sunny with a chance yes
look at her butt chin she's gonna have
anal sex with her butt chin that's Ben
Affleck chin right there where it is
there are a bike in that gym look at
that cleave over 20 images of what
appeared to be her in a raft of
compromising positions as the quote
didn't she just get through some trial
then she cut herself for some such [ __ ]
the cutter she was he was she was the
one with the way the the eating disorder
in the cutting then she started to look
good and said I'm gonna take a raft of
compromising position photos
but they have not been leaked we can't
find them anywhere which I find
unacceptable in a world where NSA
secrets can be leaked where we can find
out that they're listening to our phone
calls where you can find out secret
military details about our government I
want to see nude pictures of Demi Lovato
please where's the Edward Snowden in
this case somebody get on this
priorities people this woman had her own
issues with nude photos that got
released Olivia Munn from the newsroom
you watch that show she was on g4 of
course for many years attack of the show
she was wrong she's really good on
newsroom
she she's got a sense of humor too
Olivia she was in a friend's house who
had a swing in their living room that's
pretty cool to have a swing that you can
swing on have fun in your living room
sex thing no it's just a swing you
pervert
Muppet thing Muppet thing so she's on
this swing and she's got her boyfriend
videotaping her and this is what
happened yeah let's take a look at that
one more time I think it's I think it's
worth seeing she posted this herself so
at least the boyfriend put down the
camera she dislocated her shoulder by
the way but she's she's fine posted on
her own Twitter site so that's pretty
cool
we might need a new segment at some
point called TV shows that will suck
because this week there's some good ones
NBC has announced they're doing a new
show about a mermaid who decides to come
out of the water and get a job tending
bar in Miami I wouldn't be able to make
that up if you said come up with a
shitty sitcom I wouldn't be able to I
wouldn't be able to make that up no
title yet but it's about a real live
mermaid who decides to have a little fun
and get out of the water while she's
tending bar at an oceanfront attraction
in Miami Florida it sounds like it
should have been made in the 60s when
they were making sitcoms about funny
things like like POWs camps from the
Nazis and World War two
Oh Rambo is gonna wake its way to
television the Rambo series these in
negotiations he's going to be involved
on some creative level potentially
reprising his role as John Rambo yeah
every episode I'd be everyone out here
you drew first one miss fill me fill me
bigger killer
[Applause]
I don't know laser are you sure you can
handle this workload slide
yeah I'm not greedy lazy we do have a
segment called that movies that will
suck however that's for sure
[Music]
Hulk Hogan has announced there's a I
[Applause]
didn't have to say anything there is a
movie in the works based on the story of
his life brother he said he's read the
treatment for the script and they've
nailed the story like they were living
in my shoes he said well when you've
lived the life that hoaxster has I mean
absolutely he would like Chris Hemsworth
to play him in the film
Oh wouldn't we all I'd like Chris
Hemsworth to play me in the Hollywood
babble-on movie I'd like Chris Hemsworth
to play me in my bed stop it
play me like his girlfriend man Affleck
has Hogan and we now know officially
what Sean Connery's last film will be
everyone thought it was League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen that's when he
retired initially but he has done the
voice work in a animated feature film
that was produced entirely in Scotland
because you know he's very patriotic
when it comes to Scot Scotland and it's
called Sir Billy and as if it wasn't bad
enough that League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen was his last film here is the
synopsis for Sir Billy
[Music]
Oh
sir Billy sir Billy is a skateboarding
grandfather and veterinarian who goes
above and beyond the call of duty
fighting villainous policemen to save
the last beaver in Scotland with the
help of a goat named Gordon that's not
fair you don't go to a senile you don't
go to a senile old man and and say Shaun
Shaun we're making this movie in
Scotland would you do it for us
what is it putting time now just say
this just say these words
I'm sure Billy that's embarrassing and
the man goes out with that film you're
right he is very patriotic and [ __ ] he
loves to up with Scotland I guess
somebody talked to him said come on man
be sure Billy skateboard kids love
skateboards and [ __ ] or maybe he was
just like what's the plot and they're
like you got to save a lot of beaver
he's like [ __ ] Galore I'm in yeah
there's a guy in Canada a dentist named
Jack what you met Wayne Gretzky I was
like yeah not everybody in Canada is
Wayne Gretzky this this dentist is named
Michael Zook he bought at auction many
years ago John Lennon's tooth that had
been pulled from his head well I guess
that's where you pull it tooth isn't it
weird they took it off his ass or
something that'd be strange not the rare
rectal - now that grants wishes
it was a rotted impacted tooth had been
removed and then someone put it up for
auction he bought it he has announced
that he now wants to clone a new John
Lennon from DNA found in the tooth is he
allowed to do that it's his tooth I
guess he can do whatever he wants the
question is can you do that is there
somewhere to do that my favorite part of
this story scientists are skeptical that
he'll be able to pull it off well yeah
you know why because you can't [ __ ]
do it that's why he says most people say
I'm crazy no so I'm not the only one
shucks you [ __ ] busted your balls bad
it would be great to say I had a small
part in bringing back one of rock's
greatest stars that would be
mind-blowing said dr. Michael Zook who
drops a lot of [ __ ] acid cut to some
giant [ __ ] I'm going to crush evil I'm
going to destroy you bring me your giant
Asian women John Lennon is lonely
just imagine what I could do to you
kukuku
and while we're talking about teeth
Madonna at the age of 55 this week she
just turned 55 about a week ago she was
walking the streets of Rome showing off
her latest accessory a gold grill in her
teeth you see the picture can we throw
up there she is mom stop it you're
embarrassing me she's like she's like
the the I had an aunt who would show up
at our family picnics in hot pants and
she was like fifty something and there
was just too much hot and not enough
pant going on and just like at some
point at what point do you just say look
I'm 55 years old I can't be this anymore
she is a mad
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god that was the most heartfelt
plea I've ever heard he's like the guy
trapped on small world
however she reminds me of somebody with
those teeth can we show the next picture
who I thought it was something yeah
that's right it's jaws from Moonraker
it's a world of laughter world every
week being the geeks that we are Kevin
and I like to talk about the geek news
[Music]
Disneyland speaking of which has
announced they're adding a new Thor
attraction to their theme park [ __ ]
outta here really it is well to promote
the upcoming release of Thor the dark
world but Daily Variety had the story
they said it will be in a interactive
attraction where you'll be able to visit
ass guard and come face-to-face with the
Mighty Avengers Thor himself better to
come face-to-face the [ __ ] dick to
but he looks pretty powerful and since
we are hearing Gotham it only makes
sense that I celebrate the fact that I
can finally get Adam West and Burt my
ward where I've always wanted them right
next to my penis diesel underwear
announced their 1966 Batman underwear
collection this week oh really
we've got a picture of the ones I'm
currently wearing there we are look I've
got Adam was right next to my ball in
the batboat which is appropriate cuz I'm
sometimes incontinent so when I went
myself least he's in the boat I don't
know that I'm gonna benefit from this
diesel doesn't generally take care of
plus-sized boys like myself I'm sorry
goodbye three pair cut them up sew them
together it's a little bit like watching
a whole episode if you walk around me
you're running around real fast maybe
you can wait till they make the Affleck
Batman shirts and you just rub yourself
all day away where oh my god I would do
the truffle shuffle for that
each and every week we also like to take
a look at the legend that is Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] there are many stories
many stories about its enormous size
we're here to set the legend straight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is this week's legends about the
size of Liam Neeson's penis you can add
of course your own if you go to nice and
calm you're always welcome - Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's been
sexually excuse me let me try that again
it's been accused of sexually harassing
the mayor of San Diego Bob Filner Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big the sad Hulk
music plays every time he goes flaccid
the penis just walks down the road very
say Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
the Daily Mail newspaper commented on
how smelt Kevin looked while he walked
it on a leash near his home same in
comparison oh yeah just forgotten
everything was looking up my buddy was
Batman you gotta bring that back and
[ __ ] bring you back to earth that's not
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it rescued
Dick Van Dyke from a burning car you
might be the Hollywood helper Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big some say it's an
animal Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big the
NSA had to build a two billion dollar
data storage facility in Utah just to
record its measurements rights Edward
Snowden he's the one who sent that in
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Rick Moranis killed a dentist to feed it
[Laughter]
feed me Seymour Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big
it was seen this week with a gold grill
in its teeth Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big Ben Affleck is going to play it in
the movie horrible casting horrible
casting
[Applause]
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
the Carnegie Deli just named a sandwich
after it no bread just meat ladies and
gentlemen of New York City if they had a
good time this evening
stop it thank you so much for coming out
tonight
you guys are so damp buckets we give it
up for our master of ceremonies without
whom we would not have had three years
of Babylon Ralph Garman and my good
friend and Babel brother mr. Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood babble-on for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]